>> Beach Goers, beware.
A stretch of seaweed, 5,000
miles wide, about twice the
width of the United States is
drifting towards Florida's
coast.
And it's a seaweed variety
called sargasm that forms large
blooms.
It could be the largest on
record.
I'm joined now by Dr. Tracy
fenara.
Good to see you.
Where is this collection of
clumps of seaweed?
Where's it heading?
>> We get a bloom every year.
It's been going on for hundreds
of years.
It comes from the north
atlantic.
It's in the caribbean and
eventually into the gulf.
We don't know exactly where it
will be in peak season and how
much of it will come to our
shores and hit our beaches in
southwest Florida.
But this bloom has increased in
size.
Doubled from December to
January and now is still
growing.
>> Okay.
So it sounds yucky.
There's an upside to this,
right?
It does provide some shelter.
Maybe even some food to a lot
of marine life.
So explain, I guess, how mother
nature sees benefits of the
sargassum.
>> Oh, yeah.
Sargassum patches are floating
and moving ecosystem.
They're essential for crabs and
eels and important fish like
amber jacks, jacks and
mahimahi.
It plays a huge role in our
ecosystem.
In addition to that, it's a
carbon mechanism as well.
>> So then, are there also
dangers with it?
>> Yeah.
Well, so it is nontoxic algae.
It's a nontoxic species.
When it comes to shore in mass
amounts, that's when it can be
a nuisance and be a problem.
So it can come to the shore,
black out sunlight.
Photo saint thinks can't take
place.
It can have areas with low to
no oxygen further causing
problems.
It can suffocate coral reefs,
interfere with turtle
testerring.
For beach Goers, it can be a
gross day at the beach.
>> Right.
Because it's so fragrant.
It's a strong smell.
I guess with people for
respiratory problems, it can be
a real problem.
Is that true?
>> Yeah.
Sulfur dioxide, one of the
gases that is released from the
decomposing sargassum smells
like rotten eggs and can give
you itchy eyes.
What's the one two punch for
southwest Florida is we have an
ongoing toxic species.
They're known as Florida red
tide.
That bloom is already plaguing
southwest Florida.
It not only causes mass
wildlife death but can attach
on a sea particles and cause
people with respiratory issues.
>> So this sargassum and the
red tide are coexisting in
southwest Florida.
Do we know whether there's
going to be, I guess a greater
integration of those two on one
side of the coast versus the
other?
>> That's a really great
question.
Florida red tide is at the gulf
of Mexico.
It mostly impacts the west side
of Florida.
In June, when we see sargassum
come to shore, that's the
question.
Will the red tide bloom be
intense and will the sargassum
interfere in the sense that it
will outcompete hopefully
Florida red tide, suffocate
Florida red tide?
If it comes to shore and starts